take great cocktails are through the  roof yeah that sounds great  James double jinx triple jinx pinched  poked yoga code are we trapped like this  forever  that one's mine hey you go  Thanks yeah I'll get my own we have had  a lot of sick day so everyone please  remember to get your shots say it with  me  Circle Circle dot dot Circle now I had  my booty shot I'm sorry to complain but  guys being really inappropriate  well that is awful Bob we have a strict  no tattling policy here it's very clear  I'm gonna let you off this time but next  time you will receive a purple nurple  our sales for this past year were  incredible and I'm excited to look into  our predictions of next year's growth  can I get a color green G RB  that's it everybody I quit this laptop  the got dibs on the picture of his wife